it is Super Bowl week for Simpson left
go how you guys doing Oh doing great
doing great how are you well technically
I'm in the past the future and the
president of our time you are so tricky
this podcast is coming out Monday
morning which means it's the start of
Super Bowl week Sims has been in Atlanta
since Sunday I and Josh that's not the
correct way to say that that's right
our landing this morning but we needed
to get a podcast out to you guys because
we know it's the biggest week of the
year Sims isn't happy but I am thrilled
exams will be there on Monday to do the
podcast you guys are lazier and getting
there late I don't know what else to say
so instead we're doing it in a monsoon
on Thursday in New York so of course you
guys are there Dan Tana's Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday we have three
podcasts I had made explode all morning
and now Sims is making fun of me for
puffing my chest out and then deciding
not to cut the podcast now I would I
think it's called a Mockingbird they
make their chest go out to improve when
their press or no they impress their
Erika's why do I want to impress Erika
they flex their breasts that's how I
want Erika over I was at the bar I
puffed my chest out and she noticed she
said who's your chest calves I was
wearing shorts so yeah that's enough
about my calves so we're gonna be
spending a lot of time during the week
talking about the games interviewing
players we have a great lineup I'm
hearing a possibility that a world
famous DJ might be intro us every day I
saw on Instagram his ticket I'd only
give it away but jay-z
but what we've done is we put out on
social Twitter Instagram all that stuff
what would your questions be for a
mailbag so we're gonna do one some
football some fun some pod just to kind
of set the tone and Josh is gonna be our
fearless driver yes and just to remind
everyone cuz we do this for every mail
bag it was not that long ago that we
would put out a request for questions
yes and the only people that would
respond were mark Bajan and Seahawks
Scout yeah we would have to make up
names
where are those you know they sent some
questions I have been there from them of
years but we got like 800 questions in a
span of two hours so it's like real big
time Beijing I was like Josh let's do
this like the night before so I have
some time to look at stuff and then I
started it was like what so thank you so
much for helping us do the show and very
insightful questions all right so before
we start do you guys just want to pull
up the teams now so that we don't have
to do that all right okay yeah I'm
always for tabs team stats player stats
standings schedule always all NFL Jesus
standard yes all right well let's start
there we've got this question from a
bunch of people right what is NFL Jesus
and where can I find it you guys refer
to it all the time I don't think anyone
really gets what it is so you can take
this one NFL GS is and as an ex player
or anything I didn't know about it until
I started working for the New England
right but it is a NFL game stats
information site that's why it's called
NFL GS is and you just call an NFL Jesus
did you call it Jesus uh everyone
college everyone just called it Jesus
yes so I went through it and then yes I
I had no idea about it but sure if that
was a Sims create yep nope it was not
and it is it can give you I mean a
breakdown of anything really that's gone
on in the NFL over the last 20 years
they'll even have some maybe mmm
bland stats of even history like the
scores of the Super Bowl in 1987 but
you're not gonna get like a statistical
breakdown but it is a great site where
you don't have everything in the NFL
available to you I use it for looking at
schedules it's super easy to kind of
navigate and go oh what happened in this
game because once you go to like the NFL
coms for the ESPN coms yeah I don't feel
like they have the same statistics I
find them super hard to navigate this is
super fast these are the official stats
of the NFL I mean this is where and it's
great if you're looking for like snap
counts or rosters and or like a sheet of
all the guys on the roster it's super
easy to navigate it's for coaching
staffs and media yeah but that's like I
know I mean anybody I know yeah you're
right I guess it's not publicly
available yeah I mean it's but it's
practically but I will say this if you
combine that with pro football reference
now you can search
in the NFL cuz like I was amazed the
fact that the Patriots and the the
Patriots are the only team in NFL
history right to run 48 times in past 46
now my history is great for pro football
right pro football reference when you're
trying to find like when I'm going
how does Tom Brady perform in away games
in the playoffs
I go to Pro Football Reference because
you can search all those things in
school and it'll put you up there I
never did that but that's cool that's
when I use it for the betting yeah right
yes
next question here for meters Brandon
meters hey where are the biggest sleeper
teams to win next year's Superbowl with
how it ended this year sleeper teams for
next year
sleeper teams and I guess we're saying
within sleeper teams were saying teams
that it weren't in the playoffs this
year I would say yeah right yeah anyone
that wasn't in the playoffs I would be
interested to hear first
hey the Furbush is what to make a
surprise superbowl run yeah the first
team that caught Pittsburgh Pittsburgh
certainly right if we're gonna get there
right no doubt about that
I still hey I'm still gonna hold
Jacksonville Jaguars in that class I
mean they get a quarterback that's
confident there this year that defense
is still there their own line it was
banged up this year I don't think
they're gonna go anywhere they're still
gonna be a pretty top unit so that would
be another team I would look at I also
look at Green Bay sure I look at Atlanta
I look at teams that had a lot of
injuries you know I believe that Atlanta
and Green Bay are built to make a run
right now no they need to do well in
free agency need to do well but they
have a quarterback yeah and they have
some special players and special
position around it yeah Atlanta I think
is a good one by you that definitely
like if they had Keyon O'Neal this year
and didn't loose or such a long period
they had so many issues that where I
still think they were a playoff caliber
team if the injury bug didn't hit them
and I don't know of I never know what
the Carolina Panthers are so I'm not
yeah is there anybody you know okay I'll
throw one out there believe 'land yeah
sure believe 'land is one of those teams
I would say I don't know if I want to
say Super Bowl run but I really do
expect them to be very much in the
playoff combo I'll say that am i that
much all right next question
Edward Kayal left go we're gonna come to
you first on this one what current non
Gronk player is primed for a career in
Hollywood after football
current non Gronk player primed for a
career in Hollywood adverse I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna pull up the quarterbacks
because those are the guys that usually
get the first but I have so much money I
don't know if they care yeah but at the
same point acting fame is different than
athlete fame yes and I think that if
Aaron Rodgers started doing like some
Brett Favre bits like in Something About
Mary I could see him oh you're friends
with Paul Rudd yeah sure come on by a
shoot real quick um alright I'm trying
to think of other Jalen Ramsey I think
has handsome movie star looks good he
could be like you know shaft okay at
some point in this career like I
remember shaft doing the show so I
wasn't sure I don't know you know i
remember the old shaft and the new chef
I'm gonna say juju I think out of all
the athletes that really get how it
works what I interrupted oh no I was
gonna ask about juju because I feel like
he might just spend his whole life on
YouTube right well that might be the new
Hollywood in 10 15 years very true you
know uh JJ Watt not gonna be like Arnold
Schwarzenegger in part two I feel like
he's gonna be like that how he long roll
yeah yeah but I could also see him doing
so I just don't know if JJ Watt is a
good actor you know cuz maybe I could
totally see you've got the chiseled look
he talks like rock like the rock right
anyone else I mean a Gragas type
character that I think of a little bit
like cuz we've spent a few moments of
them who I think if the world got to
know him a little bit like Joey Bosa
like I look at him like the way he's
like silly Grogg he's the same thing
that takes long bring along to talk well
he might get there I smile you right
away he was pretty quick toes they're
like Von Miller is a great personality
yeah I don't know I'm also not sold on
Gronk being a movie star but he'll get
the parts where he only has to say four
words exactly that's usually where he
looks okay my kids tuned into that
Nickelodeon show they they know Grunk
wait what you know that nickelodeon show
like they think it's the Nickelodeon
show yeah he's had it for like two years
I think it's on reruns now that he's
filmed in the Sun
crash leet was another one too it's like
is that what it is sports bloopers yeah
there yeah it's one of those like it's a
blooper show that he shows host Rob
Gronkowski who is known for taking
things to the extreme how we never
watched this left go yeah I don't really
watch Nickelodeon come over this weekend
we'll watch crash lights again oh and
then I forgot the number one my number
one / juju is Travis Kelce yeah yeah you
when you talk to Travis Kelce right damn
you're really quick
you got the look right you you're a big
football player but you're not the
overly big football player yeah like
your fiddle on a plane yeah I'm going
Kelsey number one alright guys next
question here from Randy Guerrero Chris
we are coming to you for this one what
was Danielle's opinion of Jon Gruden
when Sims was in Tampa Bay oh gosh well
I don't think she had any strong opinion
she really couldn't have cared less
about footballs so I think that's where
you'd have to start with Danielle more
than anything I think it was more just
was I happy
was I not happy was I playing and happy
whatever it was she understood that you
know he wasn't always the easiest guy to
deal with but she had no Danielle's
comments on Jon Gruden and be like I
mean he's funny he's fun he's really
funny I really like his wife his wife is
very nice did they ever meet Jon and
your well yeah definitely
oh yes Jon his comment to my wife which
is funny cuz he can be like somewhat
inappropriate no yeah but like in a good
way but like he's Jon Gruden he's got
that little smirk on his face I gotta
ask Danielle to get this totally right
and I can confirm this next week but
he's basically like he said something
like you're you're hot like something
like the first time man that was a
situation like a charity gala
it was like something like that I'm
gonna say it was like maybe outside of
like training camp so it's gonna go man
it's coverage yeah yeah you're hot yeah
something like that that's how he would
he would do that sometimes right he's
hilarious man he he was wife like John's
wife is so cool
Cindy is her name and she went to
University of Tennessee she was a
cheerleader there that's where they met
she couldn't be a nicer nicer person
all right next question here the 5-foot
wonder would Tony Romo have been as
successful as Tom Brady had he been in
the New England system and would any
other quarterback for that matter so
would Tony have been as successful as
Tom in the New England system
oh so my first question would be do you
believe that tom has an elite trait in
retaining plays because I believe there
have been quarterbacks in our history
Peyton Manning that have like the
rolodex that their brain was so
impressive you believe tom has one of
those elite rings I'm not gonna say it's
Peyton Manning I don't think it is that
was insane no I mean that's why I think
you saw always the insane relationship
between balichek and Manning because
Belichick was like I'm literally having
to compete with the other quarterback
he's the one that I have to like start
it's not their offensive coordinator I
literally have to compete with him and
what he wants to do with the line of
scrimmage so from a mental process not
saying that Brady couldn't be that but
it's again we talk about this a lot like
the environment you're raised in and
it's football environment Tom was raised
and was never free thinking probably
until he won like the third Super Bowl
but they were finally okay Tom what do
you think we should do until then they
were just like Tom you're gonna do this
and deal with it so my question about
Romo
then would be he's being seen right now
as the football wizard a crazy predictor
and all that stuff and the way he
explains football on television is
really fantastic yeah was he like a
great mind at quarterback when he was
playing - definitely okay definitely was
a yes get them in the right play all the
time they gave him the freedom to do it
it wasn't overly complicated I would
throw him in the categories he didn't
even know what he didn't know yeah
because it was simple but he was
Witten's running a read route where he's
reading the linebacker and then we're
just gonna go off yeah and then they Dez
Bryant one-on-one and I'll try to figure
out but it was it was like that but
within what he had been taught in his
football life he certainly was great at
executing it for the Dallas Cowboys at
the line of scrimmage would they be as
good getting back to that I think the
point of like I don't know if I would
say that I think Brady has one elite
trait that Tony Romo does not I'd always
will say Brady's arm is more special
than Tony Romo's that's the one thing I
think gets under look are you know
overlooked with Brady his arm is is
big-time I mean it really is it always
has been
he went through the period where I've
talked about his mechanics being messed
up and he was one of the worst throwers
of the football
I was 2010-2011 12 13 when I was there I
mean he was one of the worst throwers in
football with ten yards and more passes
like that but you know I guess I think
there's a lot of quarterbacks who could
have gone to New England like the top
end quarterbacks like if Dan Marino was
in New England like I think Dan Marino
with a one five Super Bowls it's like
Brady and I say the same thing with
Aaron Rodgers yeah you know it's hard to
quantify the rest you know wood wood
wood Aaron Rodgers pulled it off against
the Giants maybe you know I'd like to
say yeah because he's Aaron Rodgers he's
more physically gifted than Tom Brady
but that's like you never know because
wishy-washy right that's that's just
tough to to say it is so interesting
because we talk about Aaron Rodgers and
how maybe his personality would clash
with Belichick right but if he was
introduced to the system the way Brady
was where he was the backup for the
first year and then kind of thrust into
the scene right but I also think Brady
being the six round pick kind of created
that - yeah with Rodgers being the 24th
pick and falling in the draft also
created this air of like annoyance right
Aaron Rodgers was so much better coming
out of college than Tom Brady wasn't
even close no question I think that's
you know again I think a lot of we've
lost context of Tom Brady he was just a
nice piece for the puzzle for a great
team early on in his career
I mean his first Super Bowl he was 16
for 27 for 145 and a touch'
and he was the MVP but he had the one
drive at the edges even with Roy brown
on the third even more amazing because
he got like 70 the yards in that last
all right before that he's like he's
like 12 of uh you know 12 of 23 for 90
yards he's gonna win the Super Bowl it's
funny we were talking to high law which
will be an interview that comes out
later but about that defense being
forgotten so many possible Hall of
Famers on that DUI no all right we
talked about this all right
related to Tony Romo left go we're gonna
start with you on this one from Ryan
Sheree
what if Sims and Romo broadcast a game
together left go was on the booger
machine oh the booger mobile where your
thoughts on that setup okay so my first
thing is how we
Sims and Romo doing the booth together
who's doing play-by-play I guess I gotta
do play-by-play he's the guy he's gotta
be the expert I would love to hear you
do playboy yeah me too he throws it and
he caught it I would do Pat Summerall
what does that mean Pat Summerall like
when I go back to watch my dad's old
game he doesn't talk he just goes Sims
Bavaro touch that's the whole game and I
go yeah it's amazing it's a little great
to watch Joe Buck got yelled at a lot
for that too I love it I don't I don't
know why we want these people to talk
speed back gone it's out of here see you
tomorrow and I like Joe Buck that's a
great [ __ ] I love that I like Bukka I do
too
so how I think you know what I would be
interrupting just like booger
so really it's exactly just like Adam
left goes what he say yeah booger might
interrupt more than I do
booger every play was like ah I'm not
gonna try and do it but I think you and
Romo actually get along we do get along
I mean we always seen you two together
you get along ya ibadi kinship alright I
mean that's our you version Adam right
out there
he's a great guy Tony I think he is
obsessed with football just like I am
and you know I think that I would have
to be the play level would you be down
to ride the booger machine you're you're
thinking for that I want to say I was
guessing plays before Tony Romo I just
we did get some people who suggested
that on Twitter I did they follow our
instagram stories back two years again
they would have seen you doing Brian
Anderson tweeted out also a couple days
ago that the games that he did on CBS
was Sims that seems was guessing place
never I did not see that tweet yeah I
think I sent it to you because somebody
had sent to me and I sends it Josh just
like show but yeah Brian Anderson who
works for Turner he did me like a
shoutout going like Tony Romo was
awesome I've been with Chris Sims and
he's done he's done the same thing i
retweeted it you did really really what
it shows me and what I think it should
show everyone that watches TV there are
some color commentators that watch film
and then understand the game and that
are watching the three or four games
that of the last few games right right
and there are some guys that go out
there and talk about momentum and
pressure and stuff like that yeah and
just listen it's not like I think the
public sometimes goes oh I liked
watching him which means I like
to him now and it's no like some the
best players in the NFL are not gonna be
the best color commentator can't have it
all
no it's just that that's just how it is
yeah all right next question here from
Alex 6na Sims we're gonna start with you
on this one
what position in the NFL would let go be
best suited for also what's your outlook
on the Bears okay so what position do
you want to put left go at and then
future for the Bears
I am bullish on the Bears oh okay that's
the first thing I'll start out with I
mean the Chicago sky's the limit they
could be a serious NFC Super Bowl
contender for the next five years I mean
I think that's the way their teams set
up now as far as they'll Baird sitting
to my right here hmm he is definitely
like I break down my football at Ramin I
would think you're a definite like
h-back material you're like you know you
can use check out in like 49 49ers a
little fullback a little tight end I'll
need to get in the hole but also if
you're built bro sorry we're gonna won
by the way you're built not where you
think you want to go how am I guess
we're not putting you at receiver our
guys uh they're good yeah good right you
just tell the people you got good hands
oh yeah you know I mean I know you're
not tough because you've never really
had to do anything tough Wow but I think
if you came up in the football world and
you could you can learn to be that
person so we're thinking hvac so flex me
out a little tight right you're smart
you can handle it all through you know
what I mean that would be amazing at the
like slip out the back catch a ball and
then run out of bounds after 10 yards
yeah you're very good at sniffing out
the backdoor aren't you four years ago
when I met left go he was comparing
himself to algae Crumpler oh yeah algae
I mean hey left goes ass is big but it
ain't algae algae bass is like we could
put my coffee and our waters on his ass
and walk away and come back that thing
was so gigantic
I mean algae getting his his wife being
pregnant in 2008 when we were in
Tennessee was one of my great joys of
NFL football cuz he just blew because
everything she ate pregnant wise he did
he went from like 270 to 290 in like a
seven weeks man and they were like what
is going on he's like my wife's pregnant
he's like I mean I've been eating like
three bean of her and jellies with ice
cream in like 12 look let me ask you a
psychological question about football
fans sure why do we love
of fat athletes this is all sports not
just football when there's someone
that's a little chunky big baby Davis
Anderson CJ Anderson Mike Tolbert is it
because they're not threatening is it
because we believe that we could do that
because we're kind of all fatter than we
should be something they're definitely
yeah comedians - yeah you know like what
like there's something about it puts us
at ease it's like the naturalness - it's
like Babe Ruth is like look he didn't
work yeah drank beers idiot homeruns
that's awesome is it because we see
somebody like LeBron and go I will never
look I think is exactly it yes cuz
they're just like ID so I tell my little
boy that all the time what do you mean I
go you're not gonna be LeBron James I
just hope you know that and he's like
what do you mean I was like no there's
no way you're just letting you know
where your capabilities are in life and
you going through Delaine doing
one-handed tomahawks is not going to be
in your future you're such a dream
killer but it's amazing was there a time
in your life Josh 100% that you were
thought you could play and professional
what was the moment what was the game
cuz I have one - it was I know exactly
what it was yes it was fourth grade
right when travel basketball was star
sure she wanted to make the team and my
dad was like all right well then we're
gonna have to teach you how to play
basketball if you want to do that yeah
and we went out in the driveway and the
crossover was the first thing I learned
how to do right I wasn't bigger strong
so I needed a dribble move sure and I
was like all right I can cross over now
my new goal is to play in the NBA and my
dad was like I'm just gonna tell you
that's probably not gonna happen
you can work very very hard and try and
do it and that I support you doing it
and I was like ten years old and he goes
but I'm just gonna let you know you're
probably not gonna be me that's great
that he did I you know and I did make
the team yeah team mine was like second
grade third grade and I was in some
league at Rolling Hills Elementary and I
scored 23 points and I remember I came
home that night and I could and I was
like I could have had more but I passed
and like I was like I drew a guy with
like a 23 Jersey and I was like man what
am I gonna do with my first check cuz my
dad was not my dad was like if you keep
practicing right
you have the hand-eye coordination to
play upper level college ball Hey well I
don't think he's lying to you there no I
think I may be hot you know
and then I went to like an inner-city
basketball camp and I was like you're
you're the same age as me
you're dunking what is going on why why
are you singing yeah that's what's crazy
about basketball is cool because you can
practice and legitimately get better and
just be a shooter and be a shooter and a
great Gible dribbler and a passer you
can do all those things that's so cool
but then if you do meet the kids at some
point at some point where you go damn I
just met Johnny from you know Brooklyn
Lincoln High School
yeah and he's been doing the same drills
I have and he's six four has a 40 inch
vertical he played the Gauchos I'm sure
like the New York team that was my first
team experience where while my team
isn't as good as I thought we were like
yeah we're five and one in the league
and we just lost by four to groucho
Gauchos I know you're experienced though
I feel like everyone grew up telling you
you were gonna be a professional athlete
yeah well I think you're working on that
throw there Chris there was a faction
that I think like you know wanted to
deny me of that like right like when I
was a little little league football I
feel like there was always a dad it was
like you know I'm hey I know he throws
better than everybody here and the three
grades above us but my son deserves to
be a head coach in I was almost back
yeah quarterback too and I was always
like ah whatever I'll play fullback I'll
play receiver I didn't like fret over it
but then yeah I guess when I got around
sixth grade it became so undeniable
between my football throwing and my
pitching and your forehead grew and I
was like it might be my feet were like
13 and I was 12 years old yeah how how
fast were you pitching how hard could
you throw it I mean my going into
freshman year I was hitting 90 on the
radar yeah yeah you [ __ ] up so I did
yeah like you could have had like a 15
year career yeah those were it's when I
look back at it I mean I love football
but baseball when I would go to big
tournaments like the North East
tournament our teams and we'd play in
Brooklyn against all the teams nervous
hearing him talk about because I'm
thinking about me is like a sixth grader
and then like hey there's Chris Simms
I'm like wait what happened well I would
go to those tournaments and you know I
didn't know how good I wasn't a scale of
baseball I knew in my area in North
Jersey that nobody could hit my
baseballs when I threw them but then I
would go there and I'd be like damn okay
this this supposed to be the best team
in the north
so they got two hits off me today like I
must be kind of good and that's when I
started to realize it yeah another level
I guess so
all right guys next question here chase
Cohen its if each of you guys were a
head coach of a team who would you hire
as your OC and DZ and why mmm
you're the head coach who would you hire
as your OC in DC I'm thinking Kyle
Shannon Anna's my OC Kyle would be down
to work for you I mean probably
hopefully nobody else would want him and
I'd overpay and be perfect he'd probably
be like what I gotta take orders from
you
and then DC hmm I would do I mean I mean
can I hire Bill Belichick is my DC or is
that like it against the realm not have
a goal like Brian Flores is another guy
I thought of right away you'd already
take him I do I am a big Brian Flores
fan I am I think that's a big reason why
you've seen the improvement in their
defense this year yeah that's because of
him but there's other ones - I mean Vic
Vic Fangio is in that convo as d
coordinator Wade Phillips certainly
would be I'm gonna take the head coach
of Washington State Mike Leach as my
offensive coordinator nice because I
think he'd be everyone be like your
offensive coordinators weird you're so
normal and you're putting up 70 points a
game is his offense good by the way it's
good for college I mean he puts pressure
on you by just doing you know not
overwhelming you with stuff but he just
he's got he's got all the basics you
need for a spread offense yeah I think
when it comes to OCS it's the four that
we always say but now they're all head
coaches I know it's bright in the gray
Peyton macdanne wink Martindale he could
be maybe my D coordinator wink I would
like Gus even though he kind of messed
up and against the Patriots he just
seems like a good hang he well Gus is a
great motivator and certainly will get
the team to play that's for sure I like
your reasoning for who you yeah I just
because I gotta be around them all the
time and listen I'm gonna get fired
after a year so I might as well be with
someone who is less normal than you and
then someone who is just a good hang
yeah Gus could be like you know this
leech guy is crazy all right
next question here Sonny what trade
capital would it take for the Eagles to
part with Wentz and keep Falls left go
so Nick Wright asked me this on his
radio show last night he said if the
Giants offered you the six pick a future
first and a future second for Carson
would you would you go and my first
thought was yes I said I'm I'm
not send them to in the division I'm not
going to Washington I'm not going to the
Giants I think if you get a few
first-round picks and I personally I
think it's cuz Cohn got my ear about
Tunsil if I would also need some form of
player too because look there's a 40%
chance that you hit in the first round
with a quarterback like like draft picks
I always talk about are kind of out
there I want them to stay with whence
they would have to be blown away it
would have to be like more than Khalil
Mak because the positions more than
Khalil Mak so we're talking like two or
three first-round picks some more picks
after that but I will say from the
trading Wentz perspective
his injuries are starting to concern me
and so I don't think it's crazy if you
lock up foals but I don't want to trade
when I would have to be blown away so
that's two to three first-round picks
and I'd also like a viable player yeah I
mean I mean III agree with a lot what
you're saying would you be mad if your
Eagles traded like did Donovan McNabb
style and traded Nick Foles to like the
Redskins and they started to realize
like man Alex Smith can't go well they
gotta extra blow them out of the water
if they're in the division it's what
you're saying which is I think is the
right thing I should be in the division
or the mass to be something extra
patient twice a year yeah right and they
might be the reason that we don't get in
the play and then you're gonna hear you
might be the reason we get fired the
only reason I was okay with the McNabb
one is I thought he was done Yeah right
and so I'm okay if you trade a guy if
you think he's done and the other team's
buying the dream still right all right
next question Kevin Vaughn to Chris
we're coming to you for this one I trade
them for sake one and a first if you
give me sake one of the six I'll trade
once there you go that's it
it'll be perfect mark it down yeah Kevin
Vaughn to who hosted krint who hosted
Chris Simms on his visit to Texas who
were some of his favorite college
teammates and did you have any crazy
recruiting visit stories okay um let's
see yes Ramos did you go Trahan was my
host boat ron was like special teams
extraordinaire right white boy supreme
for Texas yeah and he he grew I mean
grew up in Texas of course his dad was a
big-time high school football coach so
he was my my host right the one thing
first of all I'll say that really jumped
out to me from Texas and what set
operated Texas for me from a lot of the
other teams I really was in love and
impressed with the fact that Texas is
team hung out together where I felt like
some of the other teams were a little
bit divided right we're you know
offensive line was here and defensive
line was there and and I went out I went
to Texas and I was like man like no
matter where we went like the whole team
was there this was it was really cool I
thought that's what was special
now as far as money like my best buddies
hey Bose gave Kyle Shanahan Rodrick
Beiber's tattoos left yeah Nathan Vasher
who played DB for the Bears for a number
of years he would be in that quarry
reading certainly would have been
hanging with us general Johnson yeah DJ
didn't hang with us a lot he was a
little younger than us we did have V Y
around us more vince young when he was
like a freshman and i was a senior like
i kind of tried to hey hey Vince were
coming the guys are coming to my house
to watch the game we're gonna play
Madden you want to come over like he was
around do you know where some attention
to his right now beau trahana is working
in football yes he was doing some
college I'm guessing he would be a high
school coach somewhere at Texas he's a
he's the quarterbacks coach for Tulsa is
he really yes good for a Bo Bo's them
entering his fourth season joined the
Golden Hurricane in 2016 great person
great heart um kind of a freakish
athlete in his own right really yeah he
was he really was and I always remember
him for his he had a tick he had a tick
where he did this all the time did the
Drew Brees he did this all the time
point where his right breast would have
like a permanent like scab there and I
you know of course me I call it out what
do you do this all the time for it and
he was a ticked but I don't even know
why any memories of Vince as a freshman
that you could share well I mean Vince
is a freshman to be totally honest with
you I never thought he was gonna make it
as a quarterback I thought he is going
to be a top 10 pick as a wide receiver
when this is all said and done I didn't
know if he had just the you know I don't
know what I want to say I just I at that
time I thought man the throwing was very
erratic and I thought me and he's just
an athlete who's like a speciality
because Vince is like
in his prime was special among the
specials right as far as an athlete like
when Vince walked out and his legs and
ass were in the uniform he was a
freshman else okay [ __ ] guys a
thoroughbred holy [ __ ]
like he was freakish that way I just
remember that one game he played against
the Giants yeah where he like beat them
right himself right and I was like this
guy's ceiling he was he was sick what
Roy Williams was very much in my thing
BJ Johnson I can't forget them and Sloan
Thomas those are like my three amigos at
receiver you don't need to say the
school or the details right but was
there any super scandalous offers of any
visit no no nothing super I was on a
visit once with another big-time player
who became a big-time NFL football
player okay
and he certainly was not shy about
asking for things on this trip and they
were always like don't worry you'll get
them at the end of the trip you'll get
them I'm not gonna after school or the
player but I owe that what was your
experience to what were you doing you're
like my experience is nothing I mean
nobody wanted to give me anything
anyways they're like your dad's Phil
Simms you're not getting [ __ ] you want
to come here or not was anything crazy
happen on the visit today
let's see visits I got I'll tell you
another thing it did not happen but I
had a we didn't go to the strip club at
Texas we used to go to this place called
the Yellow Rose when we were there at
Texas it was right across the street
from where they filmed you know all
right all right all right
Daisy's abused where like they dumped
the paint on Ben Affleck's face this
strike was handled it was right across
the street from where that was filmed
that was our spot I was accused my first
year there of like being your when you
were here in your recruiting visit you
were drunk and out of control at the
Yellow Rose and I was like I've never
been here this is my first time ever
there was another big time recruited
quarterback who apparently acted a fool
but I got on that but nothing like crazy
from my visits that I can sit there and
say I mean there was no naked girls in
my room waiting for me if anybody's
thinking about that I'm like though the
picture of you holding the toilet paper
well that was it for my first day coming
to the dorm
yes all right next question here left go
we're going to come to you
first on this one I'm gonna botch this
name auld win mecan't engei my cotton
gay little bit isn't this year's RAM
somewhat similar to last year's Eagles
defensive studs unproven quarterback but
with reliable wide outs and tight ends
stout running game and a very good coach
will this help the Patriots in game
planning against the Rams these will
help the Patriots do you see the
similarities between your Eagles last
year and the Rams this year I think the
big issue though is what we talked about
yesterday which was depth yeah because
the Eagles defensive line waves of guys
everyone's gonna remember Fletcher Cox
and Brandon Graham but it's also you had
like the derrick Barnett's and the Beau
Allen's and the Tammy Jernigan they were
like eight deep which is lottery which
is why after the Superbowl when they
signed Haloti nada and Michael Bennett
we were like what the hell's going on
right now I think that I don't know if
you can game play I don't know if it
helps the Patriots because I think an
interior defensive lineman you either
avoid them or you put your hands
together and you pray that's why they're
so valuable that's why I think the Rams
do have a chance because if he can do a
Fletcher Cox and put pressure right into
Tom Brady's face there really is no game
planning for that no in big passing
plays right so I I and then in terms of
the wide receivers I don't know if those
wide receivers are a better matchup
against the Patriots and the Eagles work
is the Eagles have sighs they said sighs
that's man and 5050 balls are 5050 yeah
but you know brain and cooks getting
jammed at the liner or Robert woods sure
um the fact that Stefan Gilmore's got to
go against Brandon cooks all last year
and practice all the time that's at
least one advantage and I do think that
the big difference saying Jared Goff and
Nick Foles or what What did he say they
want unproven quarterbacks the only
thing I'll say is there's one thing that
we know Nick Foles is really good at and
Jared Goff's not that great at and it's
throwing under pressure yeah
when Nick Foles it was the statistic
when he's under pressure getting hit
yeah he's freakishly large he's not
afraid of contact he can make the throws
freakishly large off can Goff is key oh
he's got some a little bit more mobility
than foals and remove but I've I've
never seen foals act sometimes the way
golf does under pressure not saying that
golf is
crazy there's a lot more guys crazy than
him but I thought had some moments of
you like we were like damn he's cracking
under pressure yes it's not the same
whereas like foals will hit that throat
of Clemente with a guy in his face and
you're like why how did you even throw
that yeah right what do you think about
Patriots game planning for the Rams is
necessarily carries over that my big
thing would be left Co made a lot of
good points the depth is definitely not
quite the same the Rams might be a
little more top-heavy with superstars
the biggest thing I say is the Eagles
again I think we can't forget they were
one of the biggest teams in football
like they like I always go into like if
there was a bar fight that broke out
last year the Eagles would have been in
the final three like they no matter what
the Rams are a little more speed
predicated across the line they don't
have a Brendan Brooks at right guard
they don't have Jason Peters or or Lane
Johnson they don't have you know
Fletcher Cox like you said and when I
turn it on and when I think about game
planning it would have helped if they
were playing a Frank Wright or a D
filippo offense then it would help more
because it would been similar scheme
wise to last year player wise you just
go well they just face Chris Jones they
just faced Bose and Ingram you know you
get used to it all right next question
Chris we are coming to you first on this
one this one is from Beijing at
double-oh-seven
why don't often tsa's use more designed
pump fakes similar to a play-action I
feel like you could get a lot of guys to
bite on a well disguised pump fake not
the two-hand half pump but a legitimate
pump fake to the flat or the crosser to
open up a deeper route yeah I mean
that's it's a valid question you're
right we don't really see anybody do it
on consistent basis right now Brees
doesn't he definitely will to manipulate
coverage he does like that little shy
yes holder you know just a little
shoulder flinch just to get guys to move
Rodgers will do it certainly Big Ben was
the best I ever saw do it at a period of
time there you remember he would do a
full pump right no how did the ball not
exactly right Big Ben was as good as
I've ever seen at doing that the thing
that I think drives coaches crazy about
that at times is then they go wait no he
was open right then but you were pumping
to the first guy now you've missed him
right so that's where I think it
sometimes gets annoying to a coach too
he tries to coach you out of it in those
type of situations but yeah more than
not the pump is called you know
especially like we saw Brady throw what
the out and up to Dorsett at the end of
the first half he pumped it out and
threw the up and that was it but you
know guys like mahomes you'll see them
the pump
you're not gonna pump always on every
throw it can't be like a preconceived
thing always you know what I mean like I
said you could go back and go oh okay I
want to pump the shallow across to move
them but you don't know really if the
guys movable until the moment comes
right where you go oh his eyes are
actually over there
let me manipulate him just a little bit
more to get the guy behind him to wide
open you know just pump just to go I'm
gonna pump you know that's what I didn't
mad and it worked all the time when they
brought in that vision cone up swing
through when I used to have two big big
ben and scout team i used to love it cuz
I was like yeah I feel like I'm in the
backyard again here this is like
pointing to people fakin and they would
tell me to do it and I was like okay
yeah I got it down i watch Big Ben on
film before we came out here you're a
great quarterback impersonators
I am I really would I would take pride
in it like I would watch the other teams
guys her scout team to go like oh this
is what he does he does this move in the
pocket a lot or he does that just to
take little things to help the defense
did any of the defensive guys after the
game ever see like oh you were like oh
the way you did it in practice was just
like he did it in Annecy I got great
reviews for my Peyton Manning stuff like
just my impersonations but my doing is
gymnastics at the line of scrimmage
having a little knowledge of some of the
things he set at the line of scrimmage
and yet trying to execute that weighs
like Schwartz and some of the secondary
guys would always be like man you were
amazing being Payton this week like that
was great stuff so would you so it's so
interesting because were you on the
roster at that time I was yeah so like
if you had to play like let's say there
were some injuries yeah you've spent the
entire week study here hatin Manning's
mannerisms and just getting ready to be
an actor but now they're like holy crap
how many plays of our PlayBook do you do
yeah I mean no I'd be all over our
playbook but yes you could get in some
bad habits physically cuz you're
starting to do something that's really
not you and you're trying to intimidate
somebody else Chris walks out and he's
just yelling Omaha at the line of
scrimmage it happen to me I'll say this
it's like
day-lewis he like can't lose the actor
after a movie I'm still Abraham lick it
is weird
I'm not gonna lie there was there what
happened well there was a week I had to
come in for Kyle Orton in Washington
once and I had just spent the previous
week being Big Ben all week and I
remember my first few throws like I
dropped back and like did fake pumps and
I was like what am i doing like why I
don't need to do that here just throw
the [ __ ] ball all right next question
or quarter back next question cup two
cups show left go this is for you what
advice would you have for a couple guys
trying to make it in the podcast world
okay well first of all great move by
having your podcast name as your handle
cup too good advertising you just got
some free promo just set it twice
check out the cup to cup show I have no
idea what it's about yeah it sounds like
you guys putting their athletic support
cups next to each other so the first
thing that I would say to anyone want to
do a podcast I'm just gonna say it one
find a schedule and stick to it because
as all of our listeners can attest to
you know when our show comes out and you
expect it there and that's important you
know that we know that yeah we don't
deviate no we don't know our schedule
because you just want to be consistent
number two only talked about [ __ ] that
you actually care about because I hear
sometimes where people that are trying
to BES piano whatever and they just
regurgitate other people's opinions the
thing that I would challenge everyone to
do is if you saw Saints Rams right and
you saw that penalty at the end don't go
on Twitter and to all these websites and
read everyone else's opinion on it
you're gonna have some klepto Niva which
means you're gonna steal things you
don't even realize you're stealing yeah
so challenge yourself to go what is my
opinion as you might go I don't really
care right and then guess what you have
a different date than everybody else and
then also give a [ __ ] about your fans
and when I say fans I mean anyone that's
listening just because there's not
really a good word to describe them
because your guys are the only reason
that we're here today and so if you
interact with them and you talk to them
and then if they give you criticism
they're not just being a troll I think
when I came up in traditional media it
was
the comment sections awful or the the
message boards are a bunch of trolls but
then I was covering college sports and I
was like there's better information on
the message boards in the comment
section and the people that I'm working
with
so stop don't don't look at other people
as they're a hater realize that like no
maybe there's some truth to what they're
saying so listen to your audience stick
to a schedule and only say your opinions
and what you care about would be my tips
yeah Chris any thoughts on podcasting
you didn't know what a podcast was when
we started this now the first episode
was the first question about cast I'm no
I think you guys have steered me in the
right direction and I always follow your
lead I mean I don't want to be doing
this podcast today because all we could
have done this Monday but other than
that we can't miss the schedule I guess
I'm all for it
Saturday Night Live can take a Saturday
off but not a Thursday pocket not so we
before the election all right next
question
nicholas jordan chris coming to you for
this one how much does having a
left-handed quarterback affect the
playbook and play-calling if at all
you've told the story about Keyshawn not
knowing when your ball spun a different
direction what about the playbook and
the play club yeah I mean the play
calling all right so the throwing is a
thing there's no doubt about that I mean
the receivers are always shocked the
first time if you especially if you have
a strong alarm and you throw it Lefty
they're like whoa okay hold on hello say
throw me a few more here let me get used
to that so there was always that aspect
the play calling it does it affects the
the play caller to a degree right you
want to call play-action passes that the
quarterback doesn't have to spin around
in some weird direction and turn his
back to the defense or anything like
that so Jon Gruden yeah it did annoy him
at times that you know hey more times
than not you'd like to call a bootleg
for a righty where he comes out right
fakes the run to the left and comes out
to the right well if you've been calling
that way your whole life now you got to
go over to the lefty I got a favor
calling it fake the run to the right
boot to the left it messes with a play
caller and anything like that now from
there on out there's not a whole lot of
things I think it really is just play
action and boot passes you know drop
back pass game it's not gonna change I
mean I wasn't like oh I like throwing
the 15 yard out route to my left better
than a my right
I mean that's you know I I'd like
throwing the out rat to the guy who was
open I didn't give a [ __ ] what side he
was on and so nothing else was affected
there how long would people talk about
the fact that you're a lefty Oh like
would it be like a constant thing would
it just be like the first week yeah it
was always like the first week or two I
feel like where it was a it was a thing
you know um yeah you know I had a good
arm I had a good arm so it was a double
whammy too for people at times you were
they were like damn you extend a lesson
to be weaker since no that just I think
you know I'm just saying with the both
things like man Sims can hum it like
right so that was like a shock for you
know most of the teams I was on there
like him he can hum it but then also was
spinning a different way it was like a
double whammy yeah yeah Joey Galloway
like I've told you our first offseason
together came up to New Jersey in
February or maybe it was early March and
we threw footballs and went to a field
only because he wanted to get a head
start on me catching catching the lefty
ball and he we'd hung out for three days
up in New Jersey that was the story I've
told you where he ran for four high top
Air Force Ones and some windbreaker
pants that's how [ __ ] freakishly
gifted Joey Galvez I'm saying a lot of
effort were you ever able to do a joke
and be like hey you guys got in them
left-handed football the equipment guys
were always the king of that they would
do that so my first through few throws
it was like somebody like you know a
rookie or something like gullible like
that thinking oh man we forgot to bring
the left-handed balls out and you'd be
shocked at how many people fell for the
trick they like really there's we got
left-handed balls no laces yeah they're
on the other side of the ball and they'd
be sitting there looking the ball be
like wait do you remember he went
specifically and say it was never
anybody like a Joey Galloway or like
that is only other follow-up for
left-handed question might be what was
Phil's reaction when he realized you
were a lefty oh that's a good question I
was a lefty from the start so he knew
you know lefty runs in his family and
really for them lefty men I should be a
baseball player so he heard that and
said you're a middle relief you're a
baseball player yeah lefty batter lefty
pitcher oh man I mean advantage now the
other thing that lefty thing can mess up
I forgot this aspect of it is the
center's ass right he is used to feeling
a right-handed hand on his ass crack
right
and now all the sudden a left hand that
has over you what does it matter it's
still going in the credit side it's a
little different formula yeah it's just
a little different we're okay I don't
know I guess I'm his left cheek for a
righty there was only one finger
touching his left cheek because you put
your middle finger right down the crack
and now he's feeling okay wait there's
two fingers touching that crack crack it
feels a little different to the point
where Paul Hackett came to Tampa and he
thought it was annoying and he switched
my hands and made me put my left hand on
the bottom in my right hand on top he
goes I think it's that it's a coach Paul
Hackett was my coach and he thought it
was annoying why would he think he just
that I thought his I think it's
continuity for the center just to feel
the same hand under there every time
traditional coach and I had to it felt
weird for you right now very weird but
I've never done it like that before yes
yeah it's a few extra seconds of
switching the ball in your hand yeah
we'd have the he'd have to switch the
ball in his hands and now make sure the
laces went to the bottom hand instead of
the top hand right I went to Denver
Casey Wigman who was one of the best
centers in football
I now have been switched to where I put
the right but I go Casey I need this
laces to hit my bottom and he goes nope
this is how I snap you're gonna have to
change and I had to change back cuz he
was like 17th year in the NFL and he was
a stubborn you know just a stubborn
hard-ass Auburn hairy office man he
didn't want to hear and he's like nah
I've been for that he got I mean he
literally looked at me cuz I've been
snapping like this my whole life I know
like okay I guess I'm changing next day
yeah that didn't last didn't last at all
yeah that's awesome yeah alright next
question here Andy man so who is the
best overall athlete in the NFL best
overall a question so we always go to
the defensive lineman what clowny Tyreke
has to be out well it's always about
what we're just we're just defining the
athlete that's the first thing we got to
do you know what I mean like are we
talking about you know athletes
explosiveness hand-eye stuff like that
because I think there's gonna be some
DBS out there who were gonna have be
fast and their vertical and
explosiveness are gonna be out of this
world but the first time you see them
throw an object you're gonna be like
what yes is that the right hand you're
throwing with like for me I think Myles
Garrett is up there I think Von Miller
is a
sure I think those those six foot fought
like Daniel hunter I think is up there
as an overall athlete but then there's
also like vo Dells in the world where
their body control their ability to bend
their flexibility is so incredible IOC
verse you go to receiver I just think
it's the best combination of hand-eye
receivers usually can play any sport
exactly right I mean the ones I've
played with they were always top-tier
basketball players I'm out yeah
have you seen Patrick mahomes hit a golf
ball I don't think I ever have it just
came out today he's alright I'm sure he
can't hold on what's the fastest way for
me to find it's on his Instagram story
okay best athlete in the NFL though I do
think it would be somebody like that
yeah it would be an Adele an AJ Green um
you know even like a Travis Kelce a that
she was phenomenal and when I say
athlete I'm saying I know they're not
the strongest are always the most
explosive but I'm saying the combination
of being strong explosive also having
the touch to hit a 12-foot floater you
know all of those things can hit a golf
ball can swing a baseball back and look
normal
that's what I define as an athlete it's
not always about like just the strongest
and fastest yeah
you got it here's my Holmes Patrick
mahomes hitting a golf ball I mean piss
missile baseball New York City no he's
at the pro ball playing top golf yeah
but but I would imagine most most
quarterbacks are very good at golf
yeah very my other fellow what
everything who would be the best NFL
player that's the worst athlete oh the
best NFL player that's the worst athlete
not counting offensive lineman yeah yeah
the door kickers I mean like Brady that
was the first one that came in my mind
yeah I know but Brady you probably could
go out and shoot 72 playing golf and
probably like you can give them ten
shots in the three-point line and he'll
go nine a 10-count you know what I mean
so that's where like they're sneaky
those guys really yeah yeah usually yeah
I mean just like we saw was Sam Darnell
right Ryan could ball
all right Sam Darnell we saw him and
what he could do playing bash you all
right I mean usually quarterbacks have
tremendous hand-eye I mean that's why
they're quarterbacks
I would probably say it might be like a
running
back if you've ever seen a running back
triple-a basketball it's like it's like
King Kong thrown Bower yeah I I would
think it would be somebody like that to
like I don't know why but I envisioned
Ezekiel Elliott being bad at like basco
I bet you Jordan Howard is awful that's
right right right all right next
question here guido five four one two is
the name no sounds like a nice Jewish
kid do you view Taysom Hill as a
potential starting quarterback in the
NFL or is he a gadget player within
certain systems this is a you because I
think he has a chance I think he has a
chance to I don't I don't discount out
things Sean Payton would talk him up
like that no I I don't either
um I think he's a ball to Chimera yeah
just can't stop thinking about it
there's potential there there certainly
is no I mean I haven't and I would like
to be able to see the guy like at
practice and see him throw more than two
passes in a game or whatever just to see
it consistently come out of his hands
but I think I've seen enough to go maybe
a year or two from now this this could
happen I was really interested when I
realized what his college experience was
where he was like this great guy and he
just got hurt like six games in every
year and that's where you find the
market inefficiency that's where like
I'm again I'm listening to Lombardi's
book and he talks about how al Davis was
obsessed with always scouting high
school recruits because maybe they just
something happened in college through
the cracks right they got in trouble or
whatever maybe he started he would walk
around apparently with a Parade magazine
right and he would have all them just so
he would never because it wasn't the
internet back yeah but I think about
Taysom Hill and it's like all the things
he was doing you can't control the fact
that he was in July so it but that's
were the first time I was like oh this
kid is special yeah yes he's got some I
mean he's legit explosive the the other
thing my question for Taysom is not just
can he throw consistently when you're
taking all those hits net not just twice
a game right but also like 15 times a
game right and not just hits where
you're the one laying the boom you're
getting that blindsided hit which I've
never seen Taysom Hill hit yeah but I
have faith in his strength the guy's got
a jaw that looks like he should be in a
heavyweight bout everything I hear is
freakish from the guy it's just gonna be
about processing and consistency your
hutch yeah things like that all those
things but but the ability to have that
kind of a
yeah you know the Lamar Jackson's the
Josh Allen's of the world sure even Sam
Darnell's feet not to their extent yeah
yeah yeah the modern-day NFL if you
can't move then you're in trouble I mean
that's all I mean we just saw it with
Eli Manning and you know might good Mike
Glennon guys of the world I think
they're done they're kind of like the
Andre Drummond's in the NBA
these centers that have to be under the
basket if you can't go outside
Jahlil Okafor yeah the second pick in
the draft he can't play because the game
has moved on my only thing would be the
guys that don't move you either need you
need to have the doctorate in that
offense and an offensive coordinator to
match the breeze of Brady's right like
they are so quick at evaluating the
field it that speed of evaluation makes
up for their lack of foot speed yep
all right guys we're gonna go like ten
or fifteen more minutes then we'll be
done gabriel norbert question is do you
think the patriots dynasty will be able
to live on after Brady and Belichick
retire so let's say for this question
that josh mcdaniels becomes the head
coach because i think that's the
interesting thing is ken mcdaniel yeah i
do think they can be very competitive i
mean to say that it's going to live on
the dynasty i'm gonna say no because
it's a special this is a culture
question yeah
Belichick creates this culture yeah
where everyone's accountable no one's
working too much you know we're gonna
keep grinding right do you believe that
that there are people not just Josh from
like people like the Secretary's
equipment guys because hearing about
Bill Walsh George Seifert had a lot of
success for a number of years afterwards
yeah but when it collapsed it collapsed
hard because it eventually eroded away
can if everybody stays can the culture
remain the same I do think it can I do
and I know that's it's a very good
question by you Lefkowitz it's rare but
I say yes because one I've been around
Josh and I was in Denver and everybody
in Denver was in culture shock I think
it was one of the issues that Josh had
there is like I think if Josh could do
it again he probably could you know I
could need to bring some more of my own
people instead of having Mike Shanahan's
people who are used to one way and now
they got me here and they were like damn
life is a lot harder nice the guys in
the training room where if you could
hurt in New England or do something like
that
like you have to be there for
rehabilitation in like 4:00 in the
morning 4:30 in the morning they make it
miserable for you one right to be hurt
because they want to go you better get
healthier we're gonna ruin your freaking
life or and - they make you get extra
rehabbing they go oh it's two sessions
they know we think we can get third
let's start at 4:30 in the morning so
you think for Josh since the culture
already exists like that right he'll
really be and do you believe that Josh
and I know you're friends with him and
all that but do you believe he can have
the belichick discipline to net because
palchik never gets too high and he never
to gets too low and I don't expect
anyone to do this yeah I mean I don't
know if anybody can replicate it totally
but Josh does have a lot of those
similar casual you know ways about him
he really does it's it's a same guy
every day focused detailed game plan and
I think - like with the Josh I also look
at just like that my mind went right to
like especially because Nick caseros
still there with them Nick is his
assistant GM is the GM but doesn't have
the title and there's the knows more
about Bella checks philosophies Josh or
Nick
Josh Josh yeah really yeah because I
just deal with player evaluation mm-hmm
I don't know necessarily would player
evaluation but Josh was very involved in
that as well and of course came up in
those ranks as well like like a Flores
that we've talked about where it really
came from the bottom and it has got to
see the really the inner workings of the
whole organization and really
understands it so we're yeah I do think
that it could keep going I mean to say
it's gonna go to that extent yeah that's
that's the other thing for the Patriots
is you know Bob Kraft and his son is
always there yes right Jonathan
dude Jonathan do not overlook how
important a hands-off owner is in a
sport where most of the owners are
hands-on yeah he gets them whatever they
need in Bob Kraft he's a he's a
lifeblood in there that keeps the
continuity together I mean I haven't
read this Seth Wickersham article about
the Browns yet no but that's why they're
there Browns yeah I did cuz you're what
it's a disaster that's everything you
ever thought about Jimmy Haslam being
disaster it's a disaster
I mean his he hired all these experts to
help him hire a code listen to them and
they all voted to hire Sean McDermott he
said I'm gonna go with Hugh Jackson I
think he relates with the player
what the [ __ ] was the point of hiring
all these people then again it goes back
to my old thing billionaires think they
know everything and it was back to my
old thing right which owners run their
there their teams like they around their
companies like Auto J fly pie and Haslam
had a 93 million dollar lawsuit there
quarter than their two there's quotes
from his wife saying we didn't think it
was gonna be this hard if we didn't
think if we knew was gonna be this hard
we might have not bought the team wholly
right he didn't die he did ready
Bridgewater he went with Manziel cuz he
didn't like Bridgewater's handshake it's
it's it's like British waters gonna
weird head chick desi
but its I've shake this hand many times
it's not that firm it's some weird stuff
but that kind of stuff there are owners
that make billion dollar decisions off
anecdotal evidence and Bob Kraft has
gone look what I have I'm gonna let this
exist so I think the Patriots if it is
McDaniels and they keep the key pieces
around it will not be at this love right
but it will still be hot yeah and then
and so you cuz you said me and Josh are
friends we are but just so people know
out there just in case somebody from New
England's listening okay yeah me and
Josh are the type of friends we're good
game awesome game plan last week it's
not like we're on the phone going it's
not Kyle hey what's going on this secret
what are you gonna do against the Rams I
mean seems like it's not that kind of
friendship I wish it was but I also I
don't think it's possible to have that
it's not New England's not capable of
that none of those have time no they
don't they're robots yes walking around
robots yep all right next question here
left go coming to you first on this one
Sean che what's up Sean who wins and all
in 53 on 53 barfight rams or Pats mmm
let's throw the coaches in there to Moon
Bay in balichek so 54 on 54 taking the
rims yeah I'm taken well McVeigh versus
Belichick McVeigh versus Vela check
would be like McVeigh comes out shirt
off pecs bouncing and you look over at
Belichick and you go this is awful and
then like McVeigh comes up Belichick
grabs dirt throws it in his face tears
his head off and then everyone goes and
he goes back to practice like that
balichek would kill him so quickly but
I'm looking at sue and Donald Wow but
then I'm thinking about if Aaron Donald
and Trent bringer guy - oh that's her I
thought oh by the way I was a good Trent
friend in there
trend Brown is an elephant yeah Aaron
Donald is a rhino yeah he's got lower
leverage he's a little bit stronger at
the point of attack I don't think
there's any one of the Patriots that
could beat Donald and I think if I go to
one of my favorite movies Troy where
they used to settle fights back in the
day you send out your strongest we send
out our strongest so we don't have to
sacrifice our entire army when xuer
Donald though who are you gonna give him
that well they're on the same I know but
I'm just saying if you had to pick the
one guy you're gonna go I would go I
would go Donald yeah yeah I just I was
explaining this to someone the other day
seeing Donald in person and realizing
the front of his chest to his back that
if you and me stood back to back he's
thicker than that right and it's all
muscle yeah I'm taking Donald over any
human I'm taking the rants I'm taking
them Rams I mean in New England had a
week to prepare for the bar fight then
they might win okay yes strategy we're
talking it's a bar they're in there or
having a nice peaceful time and it
breaks out exactly I'm gonna keep Talib
in Marcus Peters they're gonna go I
couching they're gonna be like oh I got
a beer bottle right over your head
we're like Edelman's gonna put your
dukes up you know what I mean it's just
I think it's gonna be a different win
Trent Brown versus Andrew Whitworth oh
my gosh Trent Brown is arguably the
biggest human you've ever seen I mean
it's ridiculous
bigger than Tyron Smith yes Wow yes that
was the biggest human I've ever seen
yeah no this is this actually Joel
embiid is the biggest you are see yes in
terms of like girth right yeah right I
mean this guy weighs yeah you know 40
pounds more than Jimmy Hecker would
destroy the other punter right Johnny
Hecker's like six pounds Hector would be
great I'm going Rams own ass absolute
fight all right next question Nate
brisson for Simms what position do you
want Philip to play if he made the NFL
wide receiver quarterback I think it
would be one of those two he does like
to write wide receiver but I mean I
think quarterback is what he would want
to do it seems to be where his passion
is so yes I guess it would be
Danyelle discussed how you're gonna
handle expectations and pressure not to
get soup no yeah no I don't know we
really haven't I mean I think you know
me well enough to know I'm very honest
with my kid yeah
he's he has a lot of the similarities
where I do where where I was at that age
where I took it as like um oh I hear
people whispering about me or I hear
them saying bad things about my dad now
I'm gonna go out here and score 40 on
their son and they're gonna really know
you're someone say something I'd just
think he knows that people know him he
gets you know he can feel yeah right and
he he he enjoys performing and going up
see that's a huge thing watch me watch
me shoot this shot and I think he's all
in fact you built up the confidence I
think no I really have it I think that
kind of came in and naturally with him
you know the things I'd ever say to him
like comments why is this okay man I
mean you know you got a ball in your
hand you keep playing whatever you're
gonna get better I promise you that
those are the things that I say maybe to
build his confidence I'm not letting my
kid use a stroller
you know I'm building those leg muscles
up and right from the start right away
yeah yeah come on I'm not carrying
either we're a Disney World yeah yeah no
all right if you're staying here you're
stuck in Space Mountain
search for you kid I talked to kids like
they're adults I know like that's one of
my thing I talk to dogs like that too
like I'll be walking down the street but
like what up dog and then the owner
would be like hey hey I wasn't talking
to your dog I don't believe in baby talk
yeah I hear you there you're gonna have
a little baby talk when there is cam
with his daughter and he was like you
can't help yeah you can't just like yeah
I want my kid functioning in an adult
reading level by one good luck with that
in koi M coil 17 do quarterbacks have a
preferred hashmark to throw from I
noticed Brady wanted the ball on the far
right hash versus the Chiefs when the
refs asked yeah I think it was more not
necessarily with him but that's probably
McDaniels in his ear going we want the
ball in the hash for this play there's
something to do specifically with the
play the hashes for the quarterbacks in
the NFL it's just it's not a it's not a
big deal first of all they're more
talented than the college guys and since
the hashes are so much closer together
you know you're in the middle of the
field no matter what as compared to
college where you're like oh they want
me to throw the out out at the left
let's go on the left hash it's a 10 yard
shorter throw right my Madden follow-up
question would be I always like to have
like
is going to the bigger side of the field
there was more space sure is the NFL
like that - you're like we're doing a
screen to the left let's get it on the
right hash certain plays definitely yes
yes you're definitely gonna go like Oh
we'd rather have this one with a little
bit more space to play that way sure now
you know what you can do in college
though you know you can compromise
defenses because of the hash right think
about if you're on the right hash and
now you're very close to the right
sideline right and you set the bunch
formation to the right side now the
defense has to shift all the way over
there into this little short side of the
field so much Ellison you're Amari
Cooper or somebody else is out wide to
the left and you're going look at all of
this room we got for one-on-one he can
do all this and he's got more than half
the field to run around what about what
about we know that the NFL is into
spatial tracking right now and running
right if do the Patriots want the ball
closer to their sideline forcing it's
harder for the other teams to substitute
thus they're also running more to get to
their sideline on the other side I can't
say that I've ever heard that one that's
a good thought I've never even thought
about that but no I don't I don't think
so
quarterbacks might like to throw certain
throws to one side more than the other
but I don't think the hash is going to
dictate it a whole lot hey the one thing
about running though I mean III New
England's running wind sprints this week
and I hope the rams are yes Sam cuz know
everybody talks about New England's a
poor quarter team yet because they
[ __ ] prepare for it all year long
they don't like go like oh we're in
shape we're in season shape now like
Belichick they blow the whistle and go
get on the line in week seven and week
14 and it never changes and it was the
only place I was ever at that did that
where the rest of the league is like a
word game shape now we don't need to
draw it anymore and then we wonder what
I mean have we ever said I knew Engel
looked tired in the fourth quarter have
we ever said that like never it's just
to realize do you know when an athlete
posts like a picture at the movies and
you see that like tweet that's like you
should be practicing right now your
issue is now with the athlete your
issues with the coaching job that's
right because the athletes not deciding
when they have practice if your issue is
with them doing something in the middle
of the day coach yeah it's your coach
that's setting the tone do you CDJ swear
injure took a bunch of shots at Jay
Gruden today on Instagram and an
Instagram comment to another football
player he said look he goes
some people just aren't born winners he
goes I was a disruptive disruption
because I wanted to practice harder and
I didn't think that we were like going
hard enough in practice that's why I was
a distraction but yeah it kind of gotta
be careful though he won't get myself
hurt himself
alright now I appreciate his honest yes
next question from Josh good name does
mr. number 70 Blake bortles end up on
someone's roster next year if so where
does he fit best that's really I had
somebody asked me this recently and I
died
I'm not sure I I'm really I'm not trying
to be a jerk or anything I'm just going
to say what I always say when teams
watch Blake boardís film they're not
gonna go wait oh yeah we want an
unnatural thrower a guy that's not very
gifted thrower to be the guy that comes
off the bench and just has to throw it
on a whim I think that's going to hurt
him there I just thought of a situation
no boy that would be so perfect for Sims
and love go oh boy the only place that
would really take Blake bortles and
don't interrupt me cuz you're gonna know
where you know I already know is a place
in which he's already comfortable with
the offense a quarterback that he would
never ever be in a competition with and
somebody that if he had to do spot duty
could be in an offense where maybe they
used his running and it's not gonna be
that much of a poll what if Blake
bortles gets signed by the Packers what
if he's backing up Aaron Rodgers and
Nathaniel Hackett's offense because he
already knows it he's non-threatening
he's a good guy to have in the room he
can make it really any kid I don't know
if he's gonna explain the offense to
Aaron Rodgers could he certainly will at
the start if he's there if number one
and number seventy are in the same
locker room yes
oh you're number two now that shirt
missing you're number two oh yeah I have
mahomes at number one gosh damn just one
year prisoner of the moment jeez Louise
can't believe you're turning on where do
you have them homes right now - so you
have Rodgers one mahomes - so going
riders one in Rogers on Kansas City has
been in the same scenario and maybe with
a one I don't think so number three
that's a good question I don't even
Hawaii I'm at number three I haven't
really had to do this in a while yeah
we'll do this after this yeah but okay
rustles rustles I think probably the guy
I do look at Russell well we're doing
this to Brady again [ __ ]
yeah well Brady's not there at this
point but all right let me get this last
question fold up here you know again
like you want to hear some food for
thought with Brady right okay this is
just like something that I am i we all
wax poetically he's amazing again I'm
just giving food for thought to put
things in perspective for people all
right we go Brady we go oh look at this
late game magic and he executes and he's
clutches hell but really what are we
looking at I mean a slant route to Grunk
I know everyone in the video I know I'm
not trying to be a jerk I'm just trying
to say that and then I want to go okay
now let's look at Aaron Rodgers degree
of difficulty in these Simpsons Oh
fadeaway 35 yarder with a guy in his
face over a hand for a touchdown against
the 49ers oh I'm in the pocket I
scramble left I stop I continue to
scramble 40-yard laser down the
sidelines to beat the Dallas Cowboys in
divisional playoff game it's not an
indictment on Brady I'm just saying that
Brady is set up to deliver more in those
situations I just want to add to him
saying wax poetic this is a phrase now
that's like burned into your Lexus
yeah and it started from editors at the
old bleacher report office Andre and
Glenn and they would be like and Casey
and they'd be like oh why don't you wax
poetic and then I said it and then you
took it I guess I'm looking to the
origin yeah it goes back to the moon
with waxes and waning Zanden like the
1500s it started to be used as a
describer oh but I just I like the man
you love wax Poe I did I definitely does
it's a great all right so last question
here related to that a bunch of people
ask this what is our favorite Sims ISM
as a podcast so we've got piss missile
we've got rocket wobbler we've got
reading between the lines between the
tea leaves the back porch constantly
brought up these last couple of weeks
what do you used to have post-it notes
things I'd say things you say and I am
gonna say that my favorite Sims ism
is smoking mirrors because I thought
that was so hilarious that he would use
it all the time he'd be like it's all
smoking me somebody did it this week -
on TV and I thought it year cuz that was
a gay he said it though which I always
use the French accent hi I'm Amir our
look into my face you look into my face
yes smoking mirrors ah yes I think I
would say though that at the end
I'm tired of Quandt of unqualified
people making qualifying statements yes
is your best one thank you
I believe quantifying you used to drive
you crazy when I say it cuz you said
that you just used it all the time yes
it was just willy-nilly things that
weren't even about numbers so I think
having a vested horse in a game was one
of my I don't know if I would say it's
my favorites but it really might have a
vested interest and also having a horse
horse invested I've got no vested horse
in this game I can't believe I do that
is really and you also like to throw in
the white towel oh I do like to throw in
the white towel oh no wave the white
flag no throw in the towel no you throw
in the white towel rock rocky poor he
threw in the white towel when when Drago
was kicking the [ __ ] out of Paulo Creed
he did either in the white towel yeah
but I'll go with smoking mirrors thank
you it was just a class thank you that's
all I got I never want that to end I
love I mean we can we have 800 questions
we could sit here and do this all day
okay I need to do the rest of the day
you want to tape another one no I got oh
I have to yeah I do have things to do
sir alright alright so if you are in
Atlanta or you're coming to Atlanta this
is the schedule just so everybody knows
one more time pods on Tuesday and
Wednesday show on Thursday
pod on Friday they're really all the
same thing five o'clock Tuesday five
o'clock Wednesday six o'clock Thursday
4:30 Friday also I know we're gonna be
hanging out afterwards if you guys want
to kick it and all that stuff would be
great Dan Tana's we're gonna have a
bunch of cool guess it's gonna be great
and thank you for the listening all year
that's Super Bowl time peace out homey
or Fenric good evening everybody and I
on the lef koe man lef koe man and we
will holla holla holla
[Music]